voici les dégâts causés par la
destruction dans drone lancé sur Moscou
pas de blessé seul la façade de cet
immeuble le centre d'exposition de la
ville a été touchée la défense entière
russe affirme avoir détruit l'engin
cette nuit à 4h du matin heure locale ce
sont les débris qui ont ensuite touché
le bâtiment par précaution l'espace
aérien a été fermé autour de l'aéroport
international de Moscou le ministère de
la Défense russe accuse directement
l'Ukraine d'être à l'origine de cette
attaque depuis plusieurs semaines les
attaques de drones sur Moscou se
multiplient mais avec peu de
conséquences à chaque fois pas de
victimes et des dégâts matériels mineurs
fin juillet des immeubles du quartier
d'affaires avaient été touchées la
semaine dernière l'armée russe annonçait
à avoir détruit en drone ukrainien dans
une forêt près de Moscou sans
revendiquer clairement ses attaques de
drones l'Ukraine ne les nit pas non plus
fin juillet volodi mirzuelins
arrivée sur le territoire russe